where were the only show celebrating
with Adam Levine as he lost a new
venture I'll give you a hint it smelled
really good and he gave me a super nice
welcome big deal great they brought in
the big dogs you got me to sit down
that's right this is big time for the
past 14 seasons maroon 5 frontman has
been having a ball on the voice but it
almost never happened without some
serious convincing by the voices
executive producer I said a rumor Mark
Burnett years ago with my arms folded no
way man I'll never be on TV and you got
to do and to be completely honest I
wasn't sure what was happening with the
band and we were kind of in this weird
middle stage of our career we weren't
sure where I was going but the voice
became this very unexpected huge hit
giant hit are you gonna do it forever
I mean forever till the forevers a long
time as long as it feels right you know
it's nice people to give back the things
that we've learned they pay me really
well this is the con best job did you
ever think and your honest thing you do
a fragrance no the dad to 19 month old
dusty and two and a half month old Gio
sat down for our exclusive chat to
announce the rock stars brand new
campaign for Yves Saint Laurent why
cologne what do you love about being the
new face of Y my kind of love affair
with YSL for years has been way before
they showed any an interest in me so
it's kind of a dream come true the shirt
was playing in the drums that was a
smart idea that well that was also more
me doing what I normally do there's a
room in our house it's soundproof so you
know kids can be babies can be sleeping
everyone can be doing the thing I go in
there and I bang the crap out of the
drums
[Music]